So now that we have seen that flat page
tables can be quite large, even for
32-bit address spaces, and
are too big to even fit in memory for
64-bit address spaces, let's talk about
multi-level page tables, which is how we
reduce the size of page tables when
we have a large address space.
So, the problem with flat page tables
is that their size is proportional to
the address space, meaning,
how much memory can the application
possibly address, not how much
memory it is actually using.
For a 32-bit address space,
we have seen that we have
a reasonably sized page table.
So, for 32-bit virtual addresses,
the flat page table size
is several megabytes.
Note that we can have a very small
application that only uses a couple of
kilobytes of memory, yet it still
needs a page table of this size,
because the page table size has nothing
to do with how much memory we are using,
it has to do with how much
memory can we possibly address.
For 64-bit virtual addresses, a flat
page table would simply be too big.
The page table would be many
many gigabytes in size, so
we simply cannot use it
because it wouldn't fit in
the amount of physical
memory we actually have.
So multi-level page tables are designed
to try to overcome both of the problems.
We want the overall size of the page
table to be proportional to how much
memory we are using and
we want our page table to work even for
64-bit virtual addresses, as long as
the program is actually not using
the entire 64-bit virtual address space,
which no program really does.
The idea of why multi-level page
tables work has to do with how
the virtual address space is
usually used by the applications.
Recall that the application thinks
it can address memory with 64-bit
addresses, so it has this many potential
memory locations it can access.
But in reality the application
only allocates memory like this.
At the beginning of the virtual memory,
there is the code, the static variables,
and the heap, and at the top of
the virtual address space is the stack.
So, we're really talking about two
contiguous regions of virtual memory
that are actually used
by the application.
And even if these two are several
gigabytes each, in a 64-bit
address space, there will by many, many
terabytes of unused address space here.
But in a flat page table,
we had to have a page table entry for
each page in this huge space here.
So a multi-level page table,
combines the idea of a flat page table,
where we use some bits from the virtual
address to index the table.
This works really well in hardware.
Hardware really likes using some
bits to index some sort of an array,
but we want to avoid the use of table
entries that correspond to this.
Meaning, we want to have a pretty
normal page table like thing here,
and here, but
somehow not have anything for this so
that we can simply omit
those page table entries.
Now that we have the idea for
what we want,
let's see how the multi-level
page table is actually organized.